joe biden introduces kamala harris as
his vice presidential pick
while the media run cover for her
radicalism president trump looks for an
angle of attack and the media cannot
handle good news on kovit i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben a lot of news to get to we'll get to
all of it in just one second first
you may have noticed that there's a lot
of uncertainty right now like we've got
a presidential election going on kovit
continues to
dominate the news the economy is really
really up and down like we don't know
where things are going next
now might be a pretty good time to
diversify at least a little bit into
precious metals in fact i've been
telling you that since 2016
and to invest in precious metals with
birch gold that was way back when gold
was 1300 bucks an ounce
right now gold is at a new all-time high
why well gold and silver thrive on
uncertainty and i cannot imagine a more
uncertain time
than this one i'll tell you again if you
haven't reached out to birch gold's
diversify part of your ira or 401k
into a precious metals ira or just
purchase physical gold or silver from
them
go ahead and do it today text ben 247
4747 get a free information kit on
protecting your savings
with gold listen i have a little bit of
my money in precious metals you should
too
i trust the folks over at birch gold
they've got an a plus rating with the
better business bureau countless five
star reviews
talk to them ask all your questions get
all the information when you feel
comfortable
then talk about investing a little bit
of your money in precious metals text
ben to 47 47-47 when you open an ira in
precious metals before august 30th
you'll be the first to get a signed copy
of my new book how to destroy america in
three easy steps
for free again text ben 247 47
47 right now attack spend 247 47
47 alrighty so yesterday was the big day
it was the day when joe biden would
present
kamala harris to the world no we already
knew kamala harris we didn't like her
much
but now was the moment when we were
supposed to gaze upon her anew with new
eyes now she was exciting you remember
that whole year
or so when she was in the public eye and
everybody thought she was terrible
and for like five seconds i was like wow
she's good at this because she was
really mean to joe biden
and she said that he was a racist and
then she couldn't back that up
because she was just saying things
because that's what she does because
she's terrible opportunistic
authoritarian
and then she sort of disappeared and
everybody was kind of relieved but the
media was like oh man isn't it sad that
she's gone after she ran such a terrible
campaign
and now she's back and we're supposed to
be supes excited that kamala harris is
back because now
she's great at this i mean a perfect
indicator of this by the way is the new
york times the new york times
took a picture of kamala harris on the
day she dropped out and talked about her
chaotic terrible campaign
that was basically the headline and then
they used the exact same picture just a
little bit closer up
and then when she was selected as vp it
was historic moment kamala harris
selected as joe biden's vp same exact
picture
two completely different headlines
because the media can swivel on a dime
whatever the democrats need the media
will be there to
provide it so yesterday joe biden
presented harris to the world this was
shortly after
joe biden read a script to kamala harris
offering her the job it was very
spontaneous the whole situation was
incredibly
spontaneous for some reason joe biden
was wearing a mask with nobody
in sight and also he was reading off a
note card that reminded him who kamala
harris was
not really kidding and also he was
holding his cell phone upside down
but he then had a very spontaneous
conversation it's this sort of
spontaneity and joy we can look forward
to for the next three months at a very
minimum
here was the original conversation
supposedly between joe biden and kamal
harris and you can listen to how
surprised and overjoyed come
almost as surprised as she was when she
loved the bus remember that time when
kamala harris loved the bus right back
during her campaign
they presented her with the repainted
bus from the fugitive that she had used
to
bust truant children over to the
juvenile detention facility remember
that one
and harris came out and she looked at
the bus and she was like super duper
happy do you have tape of that
kamala hair is loving the bus
oh my god i love it oh wow
and you remember that was like take 37.
that was the one where she looked super
spontaneous right well now we get that
same level of spontaneity
and joy and happiness i mean she's just
a joyful spontaneous happy person kamal
harris when joe biden presents her with
the vp pick
here that was yesterday hi hi hi
hi sorry to keep you that's all right
you ready to go to work
oh my god i'm so ready to go to work
first of all is the answer yes
the answer is absolutely yes no and i am
ready to work
i am ready to do this with you for you i
i just i'm just deeply honored and i'm
very excited okay and then she proceeded
i kid you not to go into a 45 second
stump speech
on criminal justice reform and all of
her various policies so it wasn't
rehearsed in any way you can tell
because you have the guy in the
background he's playing the music so
that with
the little guitar the meaningful guitar
so it was a joyous moment
it was a joyous moment when harris was
announced at an empty gym in wilmington
delaware because joe biden
thanks to his uh his conditions being
like very very
old and never wanting to go anywhere he
went like a mile down the road to a gym
and a big crowd gathered outside crowds
are good again right so remember that
time crowds were real bad
and crowds were real bad because of
covet and then crowds got good when it
was for black lives matter then crowds
were really really awesome
and in fact they were fighting a health
problem well then they were bad again
because the blm protests sort of waned
and you saw some people partying and so
those crowds were bad well now the
crowds are good again because they were
gathered
outside of the joe biden festivities
and by the way that was like a hundred
people which is levels of enthusiasm
unmatched since the last nickelback
concert
okay the crowd gathered outside the
whole thing was was really run
beautifully
cnn reported that the gym had no air
conditioning and there was a power
outage at the event site
which is apt to happen in wilmington
delaware on the spur of the moment
because this thing is being run like a
third grade secretary for student
council campaign
basically never leave your homeroom but
campaign from your homeroom joe biden so
here was cnn reporting that yesterday
we know they're delayed right now it was
supposed to start earlier and i'm just
hearing in my ear that there was a
there's a issue with the power outage at
the school is that what
is behind the delay it it certainly
could be one of the reasons behind the
the delay but we also know that biden
campaign events
often are late we do expect this uh
momentarily but
again not probably the best uh rollout
to look that they had planned
so biden was about an hour late to this
the good news is that joe biden didn't
notice that
he just called it early bird dinner so
then joe biden finally arrives to
introduce
tomale harris and he makes it perfectly
obvious the appeal of kamal harris
namely she checks all the intersectional
boxes right we can
i'll be real about this if joe biden had
his brothers he would have chosen
somebody who was not kamal harris he
would have chosen perhaps amy klobuchar
with whom he is close and whose
endorsement
at the at the sort of tail end of the
campaign actually meant an awful lot
because it helped shift support behind
biden
right before the south carolina
primaries he he may have preferred cory
booker he may prefer to man but he box
himself into a corner by saying i need
a black woman basically and that limited
his choices to a bunch of people who are
not senators and kamala harris
so then he's going to use that as a
weapon so his new weapon is
here is my vp pick kamal harris a black
woman and if you attack her in any way
it's because she is black
and also a woman that is the only reason
that you would be upset with comel
harris is because she's black
and also a woman not that she's a
terrible candidate not that she's a
radical not that she's an authoritarian
with opportunistic tendencies
nope the reason you're attacking her is
because she's black and a woman
so here's joe biden doing this routine
yesterday
donald trump has already started his
attacks
calling kamala quote nasty
whining about how she is quote mean
to his appointees it's no surprise
because whining is what donald trump
does best better than any president
american history
is anyone surprised donald trump has a
problem with a strong woman or strong
women across the board
okay and this is going to be the line
and get ready for the media to cover
this line whatever the democrat line is
the beautiful thing about the media is
they really are a fantastic
communications organ for the democratic
party
it's truly incredible this was the line
as we'll see like all of yesterday will
be for all of today it will be for the
next several weeks
is that any attack on kamala harris
betrays your sexism and your
racism wait for it
sexism and racism okay there's gonna be
a lot of that
okay so then biden said let me introduce
you to your next vice president
kamala harris in an empty gym and she's
looking at him
with the uh with the cheshire cat smile
joe get a food taster here was joe let's
jump on yesterday
we need to get to work pulling this
nation out of these crises we find
ourselves in
getting our economy back on track
uniting this nation
and yes winning the battle for the soul
of america
my fellow americans now let me introduce
to you
for the first time your next vice
president united states
kamala harris okay kamala here okay and
also he
mispronounced her name at some point in
his speech so we should point that out
because
tucker carlson mispronounced her name
and that meant that tucker carlson was a
racist
so i will admit that because i'm
familiar with kamala harris she's been
the senator for my garbage state
for several years here and was a.g
before that i used to pronounce it the
way that it kind of
looks on paper which is kamala it looks
like the emphasis should be on the
second syllable
but in fact the emphasis is on the first
syllable it is pronounced
kamala right i only know that again
because i'm from california but
you could be forgiven for mispronouncing
the name it's not exactly a common name
in in
i mean if you got to take the list of
the most common names in america kamala
is probably not near the top of the list
joe biden screwed it up yesterday it's
obviously because he's racist and also a
sexist here was joe biden yesterday
when i agreed to serve as president
obama's running mate
he asked me a number of questions as
i've asked como
but the most important was he said to me
what he asked me what i wanted most
importantly
i told him i wanted to be the last
person in the room before he made
important decisions that's what i asked
camelin
kamala ah there she is camila like
through knives a needle camela
so he's a racist and then i think and
she'll go back to doing that by the way
if ever it should be become convenient
joe biden should watch for the knife
between the shoulder blades where she
goes
right back to suggesting that he is
credibly accused of sexual assault and
also is a is a racist
at some point somebody in the media
probably should do a little bit of
journalism and ask her you know what
changed in your opinion about joe biden
what convinced you that he was no longer
a sexual harasser did new evidence
emerge
or are you just opportunistic and
terrible nobody will ever ask for that
question of course because they are busy
massaging her buttocks this is what the
media do on a regular basis and it's not
just her obviously any democrat
barack obama the the the number of
massage oils available to the press
in the white house press room for barack
obama it was pretty astonishing i mean
they had like
the they had all of the these sort of
chamomile smells they would actually dim
the lights during the press conferences
with barack obama in preparation for the
massage to follow and then harris got up
and uh and she just lied about things
because that's what kamal harris does
because she's actually a terrible
terrible person and a bad politician
so yesterday she she gets up and she
says
you know the trump administration really
screwed up the response to covet now
there are things you can say here that
would make some sense right they should
have accelerated the testing how is it
that we're several months in here and
the testing delays are still so great
that if you're in new jersey and you get
a test
it could still take you seven to 14 days
to get a result which is essentially
useless
why is it that the trump administration
didn't take this thing more seriously at
the very beginning and the president
didn't take masking more seriously at
the very beginning
why was the president in conflict with
his expert like there are things you can
say
and they're a little bit more shaded and
there's probably some truth to them
and then the response would be pretty
obvious which is that democrats also
didn't take this thing super seriously
at the beginning
and then you can have that conversation
right that conversation is a have a
conversation
or you could leverage the stupidest
possible attack
imaginable about covid so because kamala
harris is
a rote manipulative lying and awful
politician she did precisely the latter
this is maybe the stupidest point about
kovid
anyone has yet made but don't worry guys
she
is just a godsend she is the new
politics she's the new face
of american democratic party politics
wow what a wonder
kamala harris is here she was yesterday
saying something unbelievably stupid
it didn't have to be this way six years
ago in fact
we had a different health crisis it was
called ebola
and we all remember that pandemic but
you know what happened then
barack obama and joe biden did their job
only two people in the united states
died
two that is what's called leadership
wow so she just compared covid a highly
transmissible disease that
in fact good evidence shows now is
airborne
with ebola which is transmitted through
bodily fluids
and not nearly as transmissible and far
more deadly
but also not nearly as transmissible she
may as well have gotten up there and
said
you know during the during the obama
administration only
two americans died of wild rhinoceros
attacks
because barack obama knew how to stop
wild rhinoceros
that is that is barack obama was an
expert at stopping
death but kovid i mean let's face it
trump ebola is not any anything like
like remotely like this and the reason
that she didn't go to bird flu the
reason she didn't go to h1n1 is because
the
obama administration blew it and just
got lucky the thing wasn't nearly as
transmissible
or or as deadly overall as covet has
been
h1n1 was pretty well blown by the by the
obama administration it turns out that
global unprecedented pandemics
are not well handled across the world
across the world right now as we're
gonna get to a little bit later on in
the show we're seeing spikes in a lot of
places people thought they were already
done
spain france germany obviously rhonda
sanchez's fault in trump's fault but the
the sheer dishonesty and there's not a
single fact check of this today there's
not a single fact check
no one in the media is like hey wait
isn't that weird that she just compared
ebola
to covid when they are completely
dissimilar diseases
like absolutely 100 dissimilar one is
only transmitted again
through bodily fluids like you get
vomited on directly in the face or
there's diarrhea
or something that's how ebola gets
transmitted versus
kovid where you're in the same room with
a human for 10 minutes and you probably
a covet if the person has coveted
that seems a little different but that
wasn't kamala harris's only lie
of her acceptance of the vp speech here
she also suggested
that donald trump had mysteriously
tanked the american economy
so here's another lie will she be
fact-checked on this of course not the
media
are too busy laying out rose petals
on the path from the podium to the to
the
white house vice presidential office
they've got those rose petals
they've got the little glasses of
champagne you know but not not the
expensive ones like
the cheap ones like the brute champagne
with like the with the cheap plastic
glasses they can't afford anything
better
but you know they're doing their best
here was it's okay
they also got her some jewelry they went
to they went to case in any case
here was kamala harris lying about the
economy as well no fact checks on this
one either
trump is also the reason millions of
americans are now unemployed
he inherited the longest economic
expansion
in history from barack obama and joe
biden
and then like everything else he
inherited
he ran it straight into the ground
because he inherited wealth and that he
ran in
okay so i i have a question are you old
enough to remember back to
march like the beginning of march are
you old enough to remember that when we
had like a four percent unemployment
rate in the united states do you
remember that
because you're older than six months old
you're older than my baby daughter
so you're old enough to remember that
has something happened like an
intervening event perhaps
that may have changed the nature of the
american economy also
in response is it not the case that the
federal government between
the federal reserve blowing out the
spending and congress blowing out the
spending has spent somewhere on the
order of seven to eight trillion
dollars in the past six months something
like that which seems like a pretty
robust response from the federal
government
because um according to kamala harris
basically everything was going
swimmingly
and then the economy tanked in 2017.
okay so are there any fact checks of
this today of course there are no fact
checks of this today
of course there are no fact checks of
this today because kamala harris is a
truth teller and the democrats are
truth-tellers
covet is just like ebola and the economy
was was getting killed by trump before
kovid
she what what a stellar what a stellar
human being kamala harris is and what
stellar people we have in our media as
well we'll get to the media coverage
in just one second journalism up the
wazoo i mean they're just getting the
journalism everywhere
it's crazy they just sit there and they
pant and they journalism everywhere
it's insane we'll get to that in just
one second first especially with the
economy in pretty uncertain territory
businesses you need to be smart with
your expenses i mean right now can you
really afford to be spending too much on
things like postage of course you cannot
you need to be cutting costs wherever
you can plus
you need to save time because time is in
fact money this is why stamps.com exists
thousands of small business owners have
discovered the benefits of stamps.com in
recent months they've been able to keep
their businesses running
and avoid the crowds of the post office
all from their own computers with
stamps.com
you can print on-demand postage avoid
going to the post office stamps.com also
offers ups services now with discounts
up to 62 percent
no residential surcharges here at daily
wire we've been using stamps.com since
2017 one of the reasons we're a thriving
magnificent business
we don't waste our time sending people
to wait in line at the post office and
we're not spending extra money on
postage
we don't need to right now you can use
your computer to print official us
postage 24 7
any letter any package any class mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready
just leave it for your mail carrier
schedule a pickup drop it in the mailbox
it is indeed
that simple as i say with stamps.com you
get those great discounts five cents off
every stamp 62
off usps and ups shipping rates go to
stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page type in shapiro get a
special deal
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale
no long term commitments again just go
to stamps.com click on that microphone
at the top of the homepage type in
shapiro that is stamps.com
enter code shapiro okay so the media
come out four square for kamala harris
and they are defending all of the all of
the lines of attack so there's several
lines of attack on kamala harris one
she's deeply inauthentic and terrible
two
she happens to be extraordinarily
radical on politics okay it is a basic
truth
that kamala harris is a radical i i
played you one thousand clips of her
yesterday being extraordinarily radical
everything from medicare for all and
we're going to kill your private health
insurance
to illegal immigrants should get
medicare to the ice is like the kkk
to justice brett kavanaugh's probably a
rapist to i'm going to use executive
orders to get rid of all guns right
all assault weapons by which he means
basically semi-automatic guns of any
sort
and kamala harris is an authoritarian
leftist she is rated
by virtually every objective
political analysis as the most leftist
center
senator in the united states senate like
to the left of bernie sanders according
to many of these analyses
the media however have decided that
they're going to defend against this by
simply declaring her moderate
i mean magically she's just a moderate
now it was amazing how that happened
five seconds ago she was a radical
leftist
and everybody knew it but now she needs
to be a moderate and so thus
poof she's a moderate george
stephanopoulos again objective
journalist george stephanopoulos
who wrote in his memoir about looking at
hillary clinton and crying together
upon bill clinton's victory in 1992
george stephanopoulos
and i mean it's just it's insane to me
still it will never stop being insane to
me
that the keebler elf george
stephanopoulos who worked
for the clinton administration as like
their head of comms
that that guy ended up as the chief news
anchor at abc news it's like karl rove
ending up as chief news anchor for nbc
that that's really what it was i mean
this is crazy but george stephanopoulos
not a democratic party hack mind you
not a democratic party hack a master of
journalism george stephanopoulos the
pre-gym acosta jim acosta
the granddaddy of acosta-ism george
stephanopoulos
yesterday he declared that kamala harris
comes from the middle of the democratic
party
oh does she does she now here he was
yesterday
emily harris comes from the middle of
the road moderate wing of the democratic
uh party not the first choice of
progressives but joe biden
banking this historic move as the first
woman of color on a national ticket will
overcome that
ah that's what it is she's she's she's
from the middle of the democratic party
that's
she's moderate now guys forget all the
stuff we said about her being a radical
she's moderate
chris wallace did this routine yesterday
and this i'm surprised by because
wallace is a better journalist than this
i mean seriously this is just bad
journalism he says you know republicans
are going to attack her as a wild
leftist but she isn't far left
um yes she is yes she is by any
objective metric
she is one of the if she's not the most
liberal senator in the united states
senate she's one of the top four
okay here is here is chris wallace
yesterday just getting this completely
wrong
she did not do very well in the
democratic primaries but
that's for a variety of reasons she
didn't run a great campaign
but you know she is not far to the left
despite
what uh republicans are going to try to
say she had that
there is a certain uh circuitous route
to her
position on issues she was for medicare
for all before she was against it
but uh you know i think i think she's a
reasonably safe choice
circuitous no she's manipulative she
stakes out a very leftist position and
then she moved away from that leftist
position a little bit
when it became clear that she was
struggling in the primaries but she is
of the hard left by her voting record
you know who's open about this james
clyburn so james clyburn who is one of
the
early endorsers of joe biden his
endorsement of joe biden in south
carolina
really gave biden a boost right before
those primaries he said yesterday we're
moving back to the left
so who do you believe james clyburn
who's actually in congress with kamala
harris or all the journalists who are
busy covering for kamala harris
this country goes like a pendulum on the
clock
this country doesn't move in the linear
plane he goes
left for a while it goes back right for
a while
we saw this country go left and elect
barack obama
it went back right and elected donald
trump
this country is going back to the left
i mean how high are the hopes for kamala
harris on the hard left
high because they understand that she's
an authoritarian leftist
msnbc contributor jason johnson from
formerly of the root
he announced yesterday that kamala
harris will impeach trump judges
if she becomes president that kamala
harris will
essentially treat the gop like the gop
treated the debation of saddam hussein's
party he actually made that comparison
on msnbc yesterday
here was here was jason johnson on msnbc
got to go through and find all of these
incompetent
unqualified corrupt white nationalist
supporting people
that trump has burrowed into our state
department
borrowed into our justice department and
i think senator harris would be
fantastic at finding those people and
removing them
because she'll have the skill set to not
only get rid of the officials and the
bureaucrats she can help us
impeach some of these judges these under
qualified judges
that donald trump has managed to push in
don't worry she's going to be a perfect
moderate she is a moderate
she's a moderates moderate guys just
like barack obama was touted as moderate
in 2008 before he started pushing
extraordinarily radical plans on health
care and spending and restructuring of
the american governmental system
just a moderate just to moderate and and
the other defense is obvious right the
other defense
of kamala harris besides that she is a
moderate which he obviously is not
is that any line of attack on kamala
harris is once again
a reflection of your racism and also
your s
sexism we'll get to that in just one
second first
let us talk about censorship on social
media sites what you can do about it the
left would like to silence and remove
any voices they don't agree with
twitter for example was supposed to be
an open platform i don't
really need their content moderators
preventing me from seeing things i would
like to see so instead of letting social
media sites revoke your right to free
speech
how about revoking their right to your
data the way they make money is by
taking your data and then monetizing it
if you've ever wondered how free to
access social media sites make all their
cash they track your searches your video
history everything you click on and then
they sell your valuable data
you don't have to let them do that
instead use expressvpn the way that i do
when you use expressvpn you anonymize
much of your online presence by hiding
your ip address which makes your
activity more difficult to trace
and sell and expressvpn couldn't be
easier to set up you just tap one button
on your phone or computer you are now
protected also protects you from hackers
who are looking for your credit card
number by the way expressvpn encrypts
100 of your data to protect you from
hackers and internet bad guys
it's finally time to say no to
censorship and take back your online
privacy at expressvpn.com by visiting my
special link you get an extra three
months of expressvpn service
for free again that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
expressvpn.com to protect your data
today expressvpn.com
ben you get an extra three months of
expressive vpn service for free okay so
the other
the other defense of kamala harris is is
of course that if you attack her in any
way it's because of racism and sexism
first
i just want to mention how excited the
members of the media are and if you
don't believe me how excited they are
they'll just tell you
mika brzezzinski on msnbc she was like i
am so excited
i am so excited she was so excited sure
she was being excited telling you how
excited she was about being excited
she really connected with the women in
the audience extremely
not just likeable as they talk about as
they you know people cover campaigns and
talk about temperament
but she cares about women's issues she
she
cares about equality deep within her
soul
from her own experience we've had
a great time knowing her so far and it's
kind of exciting this big
is it is it now
it's so tiresome by the way the
journalism over the new york times
incredible levels nick confisori is i
can do not a reporter for the new york
times
he's also a staff writer at new york
times magazine and an msnbc political
analyst here's what he tweeted yesterday
don't think i've seen a candidate in a
while who seemed as purely happy and
joyful as harris during that speech
and why wouldn't she be so much joy
so much authenticity why shouldn't you i
mean first of all she should be happy
she was just plucked from
complete failure and obscurity to be
made the vice president of the united
states possibly so that seems like she
should be happy but
that sort of reporting that's pulitzer
prize level stuff i mean just
well done everybody well done everybody
but of course the real line of attack
for the democrats is gonna be that any
attack on kamala harris
any will be racist and sexist susan rice
trotted this one out susan rice who is
likely to be a secretary of state in a
joe biden administration god help us all
she said the only the only way you could
attack a wonderful person like kamal
harris
is if you are here she was yesterday
there will be those that employ racism
and sexism look at donald trump
yesterday
you know calling her nasty he would have
done that to any person
that joe biden selected on the ticket
and and that's the undertone they're
those who will not
retreat from that kind of divisiveness
and hatred and donald trump exemplifies
it
um she literally just said he would have
called anybody she that biden picked
nasty
and then she was like it's racist and
sexist to call her nasty
these two things do not go together by
the way donald trump will call anybody
nasty he uses that adjective all the
time
have you noticed that donald trump well
he may have the best words there are
only about eight of them
and nasty is in that lexicon he reuses a
lot of these terms but every term that
donald trump uses is now going to be
recast as
he's a racist and a sexist and we've
been saying this for years right
anytime he says something bad about a
woman of color for example it turns into
the only reason he's attacking me is
because i'm a woman of color
it's not because i'm bad at my job or
because he attacks everybody it's
because he hates black
women right we saw this with mayor lori
lightfoot in chicago she's like look at
the people he's attacking he's attacking
me he's attacking keisha lands bottoms
he's like no he's also attacking ted
wheeler who happens to be a super white
dude
he's attacking that that mayor of
minneapolis who's also a super white
dude
but no it's all about the racism it's
all about the sexism this is such a
tired playbook it is so
tired it is so old it is so boring but
this is the line jennifer palmieri
the former communications director for
hillary clinton's presidential campaign
told lawrence o'donnell yesterday that
the biden campaign and senator kamala
harris are prepared to fight back sexist
attacks
from donald trump super duper success
attacks against against kamala harris
and
that's all the attacks are they're all
indubitably and unstoppably sexist
this is every article in new york times
today all of them
all of them the entire new york times
front to back including the non-existent
sports section
the classifieds every classified is
donald trump launched a sexist attack
against kamala harris
here's one of those articles from the
new york times today kamala harris
crystallizes trump's view of women
they're nasty or housewives wow this is
some solid
analysising by katie rogers
as ms harris joined the democratic
ticket the president wasted no time
calling her nasty
and praising the suburban housewife he
says will vote for him his views
are out of step with reality in the
hours and senator kamala harris joined
the democratic presidential ticket says
the new york times
president trump has responded by sorting
women into two categories the good
suburban housewife he believes will vote
for him
and nasty women who have not shown him
or his political allies
a sufficient amount of respect okay so
let us be frank president trump is not
wildly articulate
it is also not true that he has sorted
american women into two categories
suburban housewives and nasty women
this is a complete conjecture on the
part of the new york times
in fact he thinks many things about
women some of them very inappropriate
but the idea that basically the only
reason he's attacking kamal harris is
nasty is because
she is a woman is absolutely and
patently silly
after joe biden according to the new
york times the presumptive democratic
nominee announced tuesday harris would
be his running mate
trump wasted no time sorting her into
the nasty camp
a category occupied by the last woman to
run against him on a democratic ticket
she was extraordinarily nasty to brett
kavanaugh judge kavanaugh then or
justice kavanaugh
said trump um that's true though
she was unbelievably nasty to brett
kavanaugh i mean that is a factually
true statement
what she did to him was nasty and cruel
and vicious
so how about we just leave nasty by the
side can we say cruel and vicious
because she was she was cruel and
vicious
she implied that a by all accounts good
man was a rapist
that's what she did and she also
suggested by
way of going after him that he was
involved in some sort of unspecified
corrupt scheme to skew the mueller
investigation or something
she is she's a cruel human being kamala
harris
i mean she's there are many women who
are not cruel kamala harris
is not one of them and it was nasty what
she did at brett kavanaugh
nasty has a specific meaning it is not
sexist
okay but every word that is going to be
used about kamala harris is now going to
be perceived as sexist that's the way
this works
it's unbelievably high levels of
gaslighting any word you use about
kamala harris will now be turned
automatically into a racist sexist word
so for example
there is a a piece in politico today
essentially suggesting that if you say
that kamala harris is phony
phony is now a sexist term if you say
phony
then that is that is sexist as well
nasty is a particular favorite though of
the
of the various media outlets according
to the washington post
also that word nasty is bad ashley
parker writing for the washington post
again incredible levels of journalism
president trump has called magazines
pharmaceutical advertisements and
questions nasties
he's called rumors numbers and one
unnamed tv columnist who gave the
apprentice a bad review
nasty he's called men nasty and he's
called women nasty
okay well isn't that a pretty good
indicator it ain't a sexist term he
calls everything nasty
he'll be like that's a nasty pole like
that's a nasty dog like a dog
right everything's nasty but if he says
it about a woman
uniquely like a like a focusing of a
laser beam
it's sexism and so just hours after
former vp joe biden announced kamala
harris as his running mate
trump reached for one of his favorite
adjectives and dismissed the first woman
of color on a major party ticket as
nasty speaking to reporters tuesday
he described her activity during the
questioning of brett kavanaugh is nasty
to a level that was just a horrible
thing true
he said she was the meanest and most
horrible and pressing cavanaugh true he
said her debate stage attacks against
biden were very very nasty true
the insult is one trump has levied
roughly equally
against men and women alike since
becoming president according to fact
base a data analytics company that
tracks all of trump's public utterances
he did use it far more frequently during
the 2016 campaign against women than men
but that's because he was running
against hillary clinton but
here okay this is unbelievable man
reportorial courage right here the
resonance of the adjective
the way the attack lands the nuances in
connotation
is often different when the recipient is
a woman and different still when that
woman
is a person of color calling a woman
nasty say many experts in women in
politics
is another way to deliberately dismiss
and demean female politicians
holy effing s like re
wow wow so you spend the first several
paragraphs
acknowledging freely that donald trump
uses the word nasty to describe
everything from foot odor to toothpaste
and then you're like but if he uses that
exact same turn
for this lady suddenly poof it's
transformed
voila abracadabra is now transformed
into racism and also sexism
stephanie sriac president of emily's
list yeah she's she's a linguistic
expert well let's go to the abortion
lady
abortion lady what's say you about
president trump i think he's a racist
and a sexist
thank you abortion lady your opinion is
valued here
i love this linguistics professor and
fan of abortion
stephanie shriok says it has really
become coded language for a woman
it tries to put her in a place that is
unacceptable to society our society
allows for poor behavior by men but has
little acceptance for anything but
perfection by
yes i am sure this is the case you are
absolutely correct
stephanie shriok our society allows for
poor behavior by men but has little
acceptance for anything
but perfection by women really i seem to
remember
like because i'm again older than a week
old i'm old enough to remember
when i did a 10-minute segment mocking a
song
in which two women gallivanted around
singing about their wet ass p
words for those in media matters i say p
words cause this also appears on radio
you stupid
so we'll bleep that out but
let me just point out to you that i made
fun of a song
and the entire world went insane because
i simply said that perhaps it is not the
most ennobling
aspect of femininity to spend three
minutes talking about the moisture state
of your genitals
and this was considered bad taste this
was considered
as though it was an attack on when no
perfection is expected for women
it's absolutely expected from women
according to emily shreak if you say
nasty about a woman
then it's really different than saying
nasty bad men because perfection is
expected
for women like for example you could be
a former prostitute who drugged and
stole money from men and then you could
rap about your vagina
for three minutes straight and this is
an excellent
excellent indicator that you are a hero
of the american republic not only that
there are articles there's an article in
vulture
yesterday i noticed in which the
columnist compared i kid you not
that particular song which is too vulgar
for radio
they compared that particular song to
shakespeare by way of pornography okay
that would be true if shakespeare
hit his head on a brick repeatedly and
then fell headlong into a toilet
and died and went to hell and ended up
listening to a cardi b song
that's the only way you can connect
shakespeare to that but don't worry guys
perfection is expected of women
who knew who knew well done everybody
new washington post report wow solid
reporting
trump said sriak knows exactly what he's
doing
aparna thomas a professor of politics
and gender sexuality and women's studies
ah
well she's gonna be an expert too i mean
she is a professor of politics and
gender and sexuality and women's studies
so she's a professional useless person
who makes money telling people stupid
crap
about gender that is not scientifically
accurate said the descriptor is
dismissive
and signifies that women are not to be
taken seriously she said it was
significant that nasty
was the inaugural attack trump hurled at
harris this is a this is in the
washington post guys
that's the first thing that comes to the
president's mind is that she's to be
dismissed and that she's a nasty woman
we're now back to 2016 where we have a
vice presidential candidate who's female
and still being judged by a different
set of standards set by men you're
damned right she's being judged by a
different set of standards
than men then men not set by men she's
judged by a different set of standards
than men
because you know what we would call a
presidential candidate who failed so
radically that he dropped out before the
primaries even began we would call them
not vp
we would call them not vp cory booker's
sitting over here crying to himself
because he's a man
cory booker is better qualified by
leagues than kamala harris
the man at least ran a city okay like
it's just it's incredible it's
absolutely incredible but
so he uses the same word nasty for men
and women but if you use it against a
woman
then it's a sexist term magically
magically
it's just unbelievable okay so this is
solid stuff
really solid stuff valerie jarrett was
quoted here too because valerie shared
another unbiased source on linguistics
the words nasty and mean are much more
pejorative when directed at a woman said
valerie jarrett senior advisor to former
president obama
and a board member of time's up a legal
defense fund for women who are
victimized in the workplace except for
tara reid when she accuses joe biden of
sticking his hand up her
there's this whole sense that women need
to be likable and when you say they're
nasty you're mean that is intended to
cut them deeply whereas men are not
subjected to the same likability test
are they not now really men don't have
to be likable
interesting because um i've been
following politics for a quite a long
time
so good journalism there from the
washington post we'll get you more of
the journalism
magnificent magnificent journalism about
kamala harris in a second plus we'll get
to
president trump and his lines of attack
and the
media's obvious misrepresentation of
some comments that president trump made
yesterday again just to be fair
when the president says stuff that's
dumb it may be dumb but it's not quite
how the media portray we'll get to that
in one second first
let us talk about the quality of your
mattress helix sleep has a quiz it takes
just two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
whether you're a side sleeper or a hot
sleeper whether you like a plush or from
bed with helix there's no more confusion
and no more compromising
helix sleep is rated the number one
mattress by gq and wired magazine
cnn called it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on just go
to helix sleep dot com slash ben take
their two minutes leave
quiz they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
they have a 10-year warranty you get to
try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it
but you indeed will helix is offering up
to 200 bucks off all mattress orders for
our listeners get up to 200 bucks off at
helixsleep.com that is helix sleep.com
ben you know i don't get tons of sleep
at night because i've got a little baby
girl and she is just the best but she's
not the best in the middle of the night
she likes to wake us up that means that
i really value
the times of the evening when i'm on
that helix sleep mattress asleep in a
way
you can too helix is offering up to 200
bucks off all mattress orders for our
listeners get up to 200 bucks off
at helixsleep.com again that is helix
sleep.com
ben for the special order up to 200 off
all mattress orders for our listeners
alrighty we're gonna get to more amazing
media coverage in just one second first
i want to tell you about our most
exclusive membership tier over at daily
wire it is the all
access tier where you can hear me curse
unmitigated
all access members get to join the all
access live that's our exclusive live
stream q as hosted every night by each
of the hosts including me
this thursday august 13th for example i
will be hosting an all access live that
is today guys today
we'll be discussing my new book how to
destroy america in three easy steps
which has been at the top of the charts
since it was released in july
got a lot of amazing feedback questions
from you the readers so this thursday
night i'll be taking questions
discussing some of the themes ideas etc
in the book with all of you
all access members all access members
you also get exclusive access to live
online discussions with our other hosts
writers special guests
you get not one but two count them two
leftist tiers tumblers
with your membership as well as early
and sometimes exclusive access
to new daily wire products you saw that
last week we had a limited account
collectors edition baseball bat
available only to all access members we
sold out in less than 48 hours
so head on over to dailywire.com shapiro
right now to get 20
off all access with coupon code access
you can also get my book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps at amazon or barnes and noble if
you want to join the discussion remember
dailywire.com shapiro with coupon code
access to get 20
off your membership you're listening to
the largest fastest growing podcast and
radio show
in america
all righty so when the media are not
just glowing over kamala harris and
signif and suggesting that everybody who
opposes kamala harris for any reason
is a radical sexist they're also
printing people's personal experiences
with kamala harris
and i i will say the reactions to the
harris pick are insane online
like anna navarro tweeted out a picture
of herself cuddling her little doggy
and her and her caption was now that i
know that uncle joe and auntie
and auntie kamala are here to protect me
i feel so happy and
first of all anytime you describe a
politician is your relative you're an
idiot
the politician is not your relative
unless they're your creepy uncle who's
staring at you in the shower politicians
are terrible they're awful awful awful
okay so if you treat members of the
political class as members of your
family it's because you're incredibly
dumb
or incredibly hopeless in your life but
beyond that
we also have katie holmes tweeted out a
weird
sexualized picture of herself like even
the huffington post is like that's
weirdly sexual katie holmes
of herself in the mirror over joe biden
and kamala harris
alyssa milano tweeted out a gif of biden
walking next to harris with just the
caption hope
guys go to church once in a while like
you find fill that hole in your life
with something other than this nonsense
and then you get headlines like this one
from donna edwards contributing
columnist to the washington post
i thought it didn't matter whether joe
biden picked a black woman and then it
happened
well now i mean you have feelings so
because you have feelings incredible uh
congratulations on your feelings
very very important stuff that people
have feelings okay meanwhile
president trump being subjected to the
media's tender mercies so president
trump is is struggling a little bit
for his narrative on kamala harris
because the narrative is pretty obvious
and i've suggested it before
joe biden is not alive right just ignore
joe biden pretend like he doesn't exist
because he basically doesn't at this
point by the way even democrats assume
he doesn't exist yesterday
the california attorney general named
xavier becerra
suggested that harris was the top of the
ticket freudian slip to the extreme here
from xavier becerra
i didn't realize it but this is the
first time a california democrat has
been
on the top of the ticket and uh it's
about time
and wow what a selection uh you're
talking about
a guy joe biden who had the confidence
to pick one of his strongest rivals
during this campaign very top of the
take out
there okay fine so joe so everybody's
assuming
quietly or not quietly that joe biden is
not going to finish out his first term
everybody assumes this
60 of the american public agree so trump
should just ignore
biden and what he should say is nothing
biden says about how he is going to be
normal and he's going to protect you
from the radical left none of that is
true he just selected a radical leftist
as vp and he should go directed harris
instead yesterday he argued that both
biden and harris are socialists that
pitch doesn't have a lot of resonance
because biden has successfully
categorized himself as not a socialist
here is here's trump kind of mixing up
the two
you said socialism will never be in
america
america will never be a socialist
country what are you doing to ensure
that doesn't happen i have to win the
election
because kamala is a socialist biden has
been brought
by you know biden he's shot he's been
brought over i guess he's a socialist he
does
i don't if you asked him what does
socialism mean
he wouldn't give you an answer he has no
clue okay so that line of attack isn't
likely to be particularly successful
because biden
is difficult to attack again you can't
beat a dead horse but kamala harris
is in fact a live socialist and so you
can go after her along those lines i
mean she's a medicare for all
redistributionist
there's a lot to attack with kamala
harris okay but yesterday most of the
focus was not really
on even trump and kamal harris the media
tried to misdirect to an answer that
trump gave
about suburbia so there is this housing
and urban development policy that was
pushed by the obama administration we've
talked about a little bit before i
believe it's called the affh
it was under the hud department and that
policy essentially
forced states and localities
particularly localities it forced them
in order to receive federal dollars
to allow the federal government to
basically restructure all of their
zoning laws such that you are putting
low income housing
in suburban areas which defeats the
purpose of moving out to a suburb if you
move out to a suburb the goal is that
you want to live
in an area that doesn't have a lot of
low-income housing because low-income
housing typically comes along with other
factors right
because low-income typically comes along
with other factors including for example
crime that's not a racially-based case
in any way
right that it's a class-based case right
people move from low-income areas to
suburbs this is what people have done
historically in the united states
they've been doing it
for literally a century or more and it's
been happening for a very long time in
the united states this goes all the way
back to
jews in brooklyn like they would be in
brooklyn be very crowded and eventually
they would
make a little more money they'd move out
to the suburbs of new jersey right this
is this has been going on for a long
time
it is not necessarily a racial thing it
can be but it is not necessarily a
racial thing so president trump
yesterday was saying
the federal government basically
restructuring neighborhoods along lines
that people do not want
is not correct and what he is trying to
say here and it's pretty obvious
what he's trying to say here is that's
true for minority people who live in
suburbs too they move out of areas they
move to suburbs because they want to be
in areas that have better public schools
for example
they want to be in areas that have lower
levels of crime okay the way he says it
is awkward and so the media suggests
that what he's really trying to do
is resegregate suburbs it is completely
not what he's saying here
again the president's command of the
english language is not ex is not
i will say exact and meticulous but it
is pretty obvious that he's not being a
racist here didn't stop the media from
pushing that anyway
what i mean is people are going to
become
they're going to be opening up areas of
your neighborhood which they're doing
and now they're going to do they wanted
to expand it and they will expand it
if for any reason they're going to in my
opinion destroy suburbia
and just so you understand 30 plus
of the people living in suburbia are
minorities
african american asian american hispanic
american
they're minorities 30 percent the number
is even higher it's
they say 35 but i like to cut it a
little bit lower you know why that way i
can never get myself in too much trouble
with the
fake news but 30 plus
are minorities living in suburbia
and when they go in and they want to
change zoning so that
you have lots of problems where they
want to build low income housing
you want something where people can
aspire to be there not something where
it gets hurt
badly and that's what happens so
with suburban women suburban men
i think they feel very strongly about
what i'm doing
it's a very i mean it's a very fair
question it's a very important question
but they fought all their lives to be
there and then all of a sudden
they have something happen that changes
their life and changes
what they fought for for so many years
okay it is perfectly obvious that he is
not being racist there right he is
saying that many people who live in the
suburbs and have been inspiring to live
in the suburbs are minorities
and that it hurts people who live in the
suburbs when you when you artificially
place low income housing in the suburbs
that's exactly what he's saying okay the
media played this i'm going to read some
of the headlines
the media played this as though he was
being a racist
this was the big thing on twitter
yesterday business insider trump leans
into race-baiting and remarks about
american suburbs
the hill trump pitches fair housing
repeal to suburban housewife with racist
tropes new jersey.com
booker tells trump your racism is
showing after president hits him on low
income
housing in suburbs
usa today critics slam trump suburban
housewives tweet as racist sexist dog
scream at play
for white voters so get ready for it
guys they tried this playbook with
hillary clinton now they're going to try
it with connolly harris anything trump
does from here for the rest of the
campaign
is going to be racist and sexist and any
criticism of kamala harris is going to
be
racist and sexist your media will make
sure that this is considered
the truth by the way how much do you
trust your media i have maybe the single
best
case of media malpractice i've ever seen
on a fact check
okay so this one comes courtesy of the
new york times and we shall conclude
with this
okay so listen to this this is pretty
incredible you remember
a few a few days ago there was this
story that emerged
from portland oregon where black lives
matter protesters burned some bibles
on top of american flags you remember
this they burned bibles on top of
american flags there was tape of it
there's there was we we played it on the
show
here is the new york times fact check of
this this is why nobody trusts the media
nor should they
here's the new york times fact check
quote a bible burning a russian news
agency and a story too good to check out
from matthew rosenberg and julian e
barnes of the new york times quote
for some of president trump's loudest
cheerleaders it was a story too good to
check out
black lives matter's protesters in
portland oregon had burned a stack of
bibles and then topped off the fire with
american flags there was even a video to
prove it
the story was a near perfect fit for a
central trump campaign talking point
that with liberals and democrats comes
godless disorder and it went viral among
republicans without
within hours of appearing earlier this
month the new york post wrote about it
so did the federalists saying the
protesters had shown their true colors
senator ted cruz the texas republican
said of the protesters this is who they
are donald trump jr the president's son
tweeted that antifa had moved to the
book burning phase the truth was far
more mundane
a few protesters among the many
thousands appear to have burned a single
bible
and possibly a second for kindling to
start a bigger fire
none of the other protesters seem to
notice or care
okay so the new york times's fact check
of protesters burned bibles
is yes they did but also if you say that
you're bad
and lying the story wasn't too good to
check the story was true
my favorite here is that the new york
times like that description is fantastic
a few protesters among them did x
well you know if it was only a few well
then i guess they didn't do it at all
a few is just the same as zero i mean we
can round down like three to zero can't
we
just round it down if we were like seven
you'd probably have to round it up to
ten but like three we can round it down
to zero
a few protesters appear to have burned a
single bible not more than one
and possibly well maybe it was more than
one bible like everybody said
for kindling to start a brigade because
they weren't burning the bible just to
burn the bible
they were doing it to start a bigger
fire that included the american flag
guys
i mean he was doing it for kindling i
mean i don't know how many times you
guys have not been able to get your
stove started and you have to you know
bring a match
you know you light a match and then you
bring it over to your gas stove you turn
on the
stove and you light the match to the
stove to light the fire i don't know
about you but when i've run out of
killing i immediately go into my library
take out a bible and i just use that
to start it's just kindling you know the
best sort of kindling is bibles
as we all know i mean according to the
new york times these people who were
burning things it wasn't that the point
was to burn a bible it's that they were
using the bible as kindling
the greatest kind of kindly you know
what else makes great kindling american
flags motherhood baseball and apple pie
these things
all make incredible kindling here's how
the new york times covered this in the
rush to paint all the protesters as
bible-burning zealots
few of the politicians or commentators
who weighed in on the incident took the
time to look into the story's veracity
or to figure out that it had originated
with a kremlin-backed video news agency
now days later the portland bible
burnings appear to be one of the first
viral russian disinformation hits of the
presidential campaign it's real video
of a thing that actually happened and
the new york times is like
well i mean it kind of happened but it
was mostly for kindling and also
russians
russians everywhere under my bed there
are russians and if you retweeted a
video
and it came from a russian even if the
video is true it came from the russkies
the ruskies
it can't be real i'm very much looking
forward to everything bad for democrats
and protesters
being categorized as russian propaganda
that's going to be very very exciting
and and continuing to really you know
burnish the reputation of the new york
times here with election day drawing
closer says the new york times the
russian efforts to influence the vote
appear to be well underway
american intelligence officials said
last week russia was using a range of
techniques to democrat to denigrate
democrats and their presumptive
presidential nominee
joe biden by the way how's that new york
times coverage been on that same exact
intelligence report suggesting that
china was doing the same thing
on behalf of joe biden and iran was
doing the same thing on behalf of joe
biden
doesn't exist none zero the russian
technique is a kind of information
laundering akin to money laundering
stories originate with russian-backed
news sites some of them directly
connected to moscow's spy agencies
officials and experts said this q anon
kind of crap honestly like this is just
conspiracy theory garbage pushed by the
new york times
to gaslight you because it turns out
that a video
that was accurate came from a russian
news source it's an accurate video
it's accurate this is the video on which
the story came
is based is based came from roughly
which regularly streams a live feed from
the protest for a few hours each night
and then clips together a short video of
highlights the live stream and the clip
later edited down by roughly shows at
least one bible burning after midnight
on august 1st as some protesters were
trying to build a fire
again i love the narrative here from the
new york times they just used
they were using the bible to build a
fire guys that means they weren't
burning the bible
i mean they were using it to build a
fire i again
when i go to the matchbook that i have
you know in the side drawer that's
filled with all the the extra keys and
all that crap
when i go in there i don't just keep the
matches there i keep a bible just to
make sure that i can get the fire
started
a small crowd can be seen hanging around
some of the people watching the flames
grow higher the scene looks and sounds
as if it is far from the main action of
the protest
so good good journalism here they they
just it sounds like it it sounds
like did you investigate nope the bible
appears to be used as kindling by two
protesters working on the fire there's
no discernible reaction from the crowd
as the book is put in the flames along
with twigs and branches
notebook pages and newspapers the crowd
does cheer when an american flag is
thrown on the flames
so yeah that sort of undermines your
case a little bit
but then people on twitter started to
repeat it
and then because people on twitter
started to repeat it then it became a
story
and this is all about the gru and russia
today
god bless it the new york times the
democracy dies in darkness media
they are just amazing at their jobs
they're amazing at their jobs
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
also become an all-access member and you
can hang out with me
this evening we'll discuss my book
perhaps i will read to you rap lyrics
with classical music as background
that's something that we used to do on
the show a lot more often so maybe we'll
do that again because it's always
hilarious otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinnerton
edited by adam syavette
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
trump weighs in on joe biden's vp pick
a wisconsin bureaucrat official orders
his employees to wear those masks even
when they're on
conference calls alone in their homes
and the president scores a major win
against the deep state check it out on
the michael knowles show